>> Tucker: FOR DECADES, ANTHONY
PELLICANO WAS KNOWN AS THE BEST
FIXER IN HOLLYWOOD.
IN 2002, FEDERAL AGENTS RAIDED
HIS OFFICE AND FOUND C-4
EXPLOSIVES.
HE SECOND 25 YEARS IN JAIL.
HE NEVER RATTED OUT ANYONE AND
HE LEARNED AN AWFUL LOT IN THE
MEANTIME.
WHAT AN INTERESTING PERSON.
HE GOT OUT OF JAIL IN 2019.
WE SPOKE TO HIM AT GREAT LENGTH
ABOUT WHAT HE LEARNED IN
HOLLYWOOD AND IN PRISON FOR A
NEW EPISODE OF "TUCKER CARLSON
TODAY."
HERE'S PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
>> SO WITHOUT BETRAYING THE
CONFIDENCE OF THE PEOPLE FOR
WHOM YOU WORKED, GIVE US YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF HOLLYWOOD.
YOU WERE AT THE CENTER OF IT.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOLLYWOOD THEN OR NOW?
>> THE HOLLYWOOD YOU KNEW.
>> DECADENT.
ENVY.
EVERYTHING THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE
GOING ON WENT ON.
YOU KNOW?
THE REASON I MADE SO MUCH MONEY,
PEOPLE GOT THEMSELVES IN
TROUBLE.
NEEDED TO GET OUT.
THEY COULDN'T GO TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SO THEY WOULD GO TO THEIR AGENT
AND GO TO THEIR MANAGERS,
LAWYERS.
LAWYERS WOULD HIRE ME.
>> Tucker: GIVE US A
HYPOTHETICAL PROBLEM.
NO NAMES.
JUST LIKE WHAT KIND OF THING
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> YOU HAVE THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
NOW.
THERE WAS NO SUCH THING AS A ME
TOO MOVEMENT THEN.
YOU UNDERSTAND?
SO YOU KNOW, THERE WERE WOMEN
WHO WOULD DO WHATEVER THEY COULD
TO GET NEXT TO A MOVIE STAR OR
TO MAKE MONEY OR ATHLETES,
ESPECIALLY ATHLETES.
SLEEP WITH THEM, BECOME PREGNANT
SO THEY GET AN ANNUITY.
OR, YOU KNOW, TRY TO EXTORT THEM
FOR A LARGE SUM OF MONEY.
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING
WITH A WOMAN.
YOUR WIFE DOESN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
YOU'RE A CELEBRITY.
IT COULD COST YOU A LOT OF MONEY
SHOULD SOMEBODY DISCLOSE THIS.
YOU KNOW, I'D COME IN AND TAKE
CARE OF IT.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU BE MORE
SPECIFIC?
>> WELL --
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD YOU FIX
THAT PROBLEM?
A PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE, AN
ACTOR, PREGNANT AND NOT HIS
WIFE.
>> YOU HAVE TO GIVE THEM REASONS
NOT TO DO IT.
I GIVE IT TO THEM.
THAT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
I MEAN, YOU FIX THE PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHAT I DID.
I WAS -- THEY CALLED ME A FIXER.
>> Tucker: HOW HARD IS IT TO
MAKE THAT CASE TO THE PERSON?
BEING ME, NOT TOO HARD AT ALL.
BUT I MEAN -- THEY HAVE TO LOOK
AT YOU, KNOW THAT YOU'RE
SERIOUS.
I MEAN, YOU COULD DO THIS THE
EASY WAY OR YOU CAN DO IT THE
HARD WAY.
I DON'T GIVE A [BLEEP] WHICH WAY
YOU CHOOSE BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING
TO DO WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
>> Tucker: HOW FORCEFULLY DID
YOU HAVE TO MAKE THAT CASE OR
DID PEOPLE BELIEVE YOU?
>> SOMETIMES VERY FORCEFUL.
>> Bret: A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE
WOULD GO RUN TO OTHER PEOPLE TO
TRY TO INTERCEDE.
I'D HAVE TO FACE THOSE PEOPLE,
TOO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I TOOK
CARE OF IT.
BY THE WAY, I ALWAYS STARTED OUT
AS A GENTLEMAN.
ALWAYS.
ALWAYS WITH REASON.
I ALWAYS TRY TO REASON WITH
PEOPLE.
I DIDN'T GET TO THE POINT WHERE
I HAD TO USE OTHER MEANS UNLESS
REASONING DIDN'T WORK.
YOU KNOW?
SO YOU JUST THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT PERCENTAGE WOULD
YOU SAY RESPONDED TO REASON?
>> NOT MORE THAN 25%.
>> Tucker: YOU HAD TO GO TO PLAN
B QUITE A BIT.
AN AMAZING CONVERSATION WITH AN
AMAZING MAN.
COMES OUT OF PRISON AFTER 17
YEARS-ISH.
LOVING AND AMERICA AND WISER.
IF YOU WATCH IT, IT GOES ON F